bonjour madame P bonjour Monsieur Albert
vous venez toucher vos allocations de
chômage mais ouais comme tous les moi
quoi ENF c'est c'est la routine quoi
mais ça fait longtemps que vous venez
vous ça fait bien 6 ans non donnez-moi
votre carte je sais pas voilà ten oh ça
fait un moment hein e ben dit donc
j'avais raison vous rentrez dans votre
7e année de pointage déjà comme le temps
passe et ben dis donc ça nous ragénit
pas tout ça hein ben dis donc je me
rappelle les débuts quand je venais
pointer là il y avait vot petite niè
hein comment elle va ah elle va très
bien merci c'est que moi vé je l'ai
connuutre comme ça V elle a grandi hein
elle va rentrer en 6e et vous comment ça
va et ben toujours le même train train
un jour ici un jour là vous avez pas
trouvé de travail encore non rien rien
ah pourtant c'est pas les places qui
manquent hein vous savez les meilleures
places elles ont déjà été prises hein
les types mont pas attendu les places à
800000 700000 et 600000 par mois ils se
sont servis VO j' arrive trop tard et
vous cherchez bien mais surûtous les
matin je vais je demande bonjour
monsieur il vous reste pas une place à
800000 oh non monsieur c'est déjà pris
et a 700000 ah c'est pris il a 600000
c'est pris oh là M dire Madame Thérèse à
200000 il y en a pas et ben vous savez à
70 et à 80000 il y en a plein des places
il y en a pourquoi pourqu qu'il y en a
plein pour parce que personne n'en veut
j'ai des copains à moi je leur dis allez
voir il y a des places à non non on veut
pas nous va-toi va-toi il me dit on veut
pas nous voilà mais la longue vous
ennuyez pas vous non on chifit on s fait
on s fait vous savez l'après-midi je
vais au cinéma je reste deux ou trois
séances bien au chaud et puis quand
c'est fini je descends il arrive
doucement doucement 7h je descends au
café je regarde la télévision jusqu'à la
fin en noir et blanc les programmes
parce que la couleur là-bas ils vont
nous la livrer que le mois prochain
c'est tordu là et puis comme ça je chez
moi vers les 11h minuit voilà ça vous
fait coucher tard tout ça et oui et oui
mais je sens qu'il va arriver un moment
où je pourrais plus le faire ça je le
sens je le sens mais dites et le matin
alors heureusement que je peux récupérer
le matin je me lève vers les 10h 11h je
vais faire un petit tour à la mairie je
vais voir s'il y a pas un secours à
toucher ou bien un retard d'All
loocation savez parce que
l'administration n'est jamais tranquille
pas prasserie là quand il y a les
élections je vais voter je regarde les
bulletins je passe la matinée les
candidats il y en a toujours des
nouveaux alors je regarde celui-là tiens
hop celui-là il s'est pointé hop
celui-là il est nouveau h c'est une
petite découverte et oui mais les
élections c'est tous les 4 ou 5 ans e
mieux que
rien mais vous savez le plus dur c'est
pas ça le plus dur c'est le 15 le 14
juillet le 15 août le 1er mai
qu'est-ce qu'on s'eni les magasins
fermés personne le travail c'est un
calvaire elle est longue la journée hein
ça c'est très long les jours fériers je
peux pas les voir alors je peux pas mais
quand même votre famille vous la voyez
de temps en temps vos frères et puis vos
sœurs mais non ils travaillent tous oh
il se lève à 6h du matin il travaille en
Bonlieu arti soit-disant par rentourner
toujours à droite à gauche ma sœur elle
travaille dans le métro elle fait la
nuit soisant qu' ils appellent ça des
brigades savoir c'est ces brigades là
qui font ça fait que je peux pas les
voir on n pas les mêmes
horaire mon Dieu on a tous nos problèmes
et nos ennuis vous saz moi surtouti sur
moi aussiz voilà votre argent Albert mie
que rien dites-moi
oui
vous vous savez pas si on va être
augmenté prochainement ah non j'ai rien
entendu à ce sujet Comment vous avez
rien entendu vous êtes sûr vous avez pas
absolument pas non comment tous les
fonctionnaires ils ont été augmentés et
tous les collègues m'avent dit nous
normalement on doit suivre alors c'est
chez nous il y a rien d'annoncer hein ah
ça c'est de la BU quand même il ça va
aller malin tout ce qui leur pas auz
c'est qu'on va faire la grève et
attention nous qu qu'on fait la grve
c'est pas de la rigolade nous on fait la
grve illimité nous
attention